the best heuristic when it comes to an
early stage founder is Clarity of
thoughtful and so you know people talk
about you know the demise of sf4 don't
softball at it is it is it going to come
back or is it not yeah look it is still
one of the best places in the world to
build a startup you want it to be either
as big as possible or it's end up being
a big crater in the ground if your loss
ratio is zero you're actually not doing
it the right way what is the craziest
technology you guys have invested all
right guys bang bang I've got Eric here
with me I thought a great place to start
would be you guys are very people
focused so like what makes a great
founder how do you think about you meet
someone and you're like you should start
a company versus you meet someone you're
like you should not start a company yeah
so so let's go here so we actually think
about it across two kind of pieces we
think number one in terms of kind of
like potential future Founders and then
and then number two like you're actually
starting a company right now hey how do
we think about you as a Founder right
and so if you think about that that
first one of
potential future Founders and we think I
kind of through a few different vectors
I think number one like what is your
body of work right like what have you
done in the past that shows some degree
of of kind of grit of Excellence
um that's essentially a good predictor
for for kind of future success right any
you know odds are maybe you didn't even
start a company in the past that's fine
um but maybe a world-class pianist or
athlete or like you've done something so
that's that's piece one and then number
two is is we kind of think about okay
well what do the people that know you
best have to say about you it's
essentially just kind of character
referencing right so managers colleagues
peers whatever I'd be uh and kind of
getting an understanding of of your work
ethic character how well respected you
are all those kinds of things and then
the last piece is uh just a good
old-fashioned conversation right I think
one of the things we've learned over the
past few years is is if you kind of do
your underwriting and kind of filtering
the right way and the kinds of people
that are going to start generational
companies no and they'll tell you very
clearly hey you know I'm at startup X
right now and I'm here to accomplish
these three things right I'm here to
learn when it takes to fundraise I'm
here to
uh you know kind of basically learn on
somebody else's dime and then I I'm here
to learn what it takes to be a
world-class manager and in one to two
years like I expect to quit and start a
company right so you're looking with
people that have just tremendous
conviction and understanding of like
what they actually want to do on the
future founder side I think when it
comes to actual Founders specifically
and how we think about them kind of as
people I think number one is like we're
looking for
is this person deeply deeply
knowledgeable and sophisticated about
the space they're building in right so
we're not looking for you know Bobby who
has an app idea that is doing it because
it's cool and everybody else is doing it
right we're looking for you know paveli
who has been doing synthetic biology
research for a decade since he was in
high school and you know now he's
starting a sin bio company and he's
world class in this space right and then
we're also looking for are they deeply
technical are they good at sales and are
they Scrappy right I think ultimately
you can be the best technologist in the
world but if you can't also clearly
articulate and tell a compelling story
and narrative around why this thing
needs to exist in the world you're dead
in the water so that's kind of how we
think about it so when you meet someone
and they're like I'm great at X yeah how
do you actually know if they're great
it's easy if um you know you won a World
Championship or you're Olympic Athlete
you got a gold medal like there are some
external kind of validating components
but synthetic biology how do you know
that they're actually great yeah so
we'll we'll quite literally I mean for
synthetic biology right like we'll
actually go into to the weeds with them
right like we'll have them in depth walk
us through their body of work over the
past five or ten years in sinbaya right
so we'll have them walk us through any
research that they've done projects
they've worked on professors that
they've worked with and talked to them
right so we'll go as far down the rabbit
hole for diligence as we possibly can
and then ultimately you're able to suss
out some some understanding of hey scale
one to ten you know how does this person
kind of fit in and then from there you
like that's a piece of the puzzle right
How Deeply knowledgeable and
sophisticated is this person and then
you're coupling it with everything else
right with kind of like technical
ability what people have to say about
them their their character sales ability
all that kind of stuff so move
microphone uh just in front like uh pull
it yeah okay
um and so as you're going through this
are you looking for specific things in
the conversation so okay you're a
synthetic biologist I guess is the right
terminology uh for the last five years
walk me through your work are you
looking for command of the information
are you looking for like creativity in
their work are you looking for like
persistence or are you just like this
person [ __ ] knows what they're
talking about and like this other person
got exposed and they don't know what
they're talking about yeah well so I
think that the single best
heuristic that we've observed over the
past five years of doing this now when
it comes to in an early stage founder is
Clarity of thought interesting right and
so
you'll go and you'll talk to somebody
about a potential founder let's say
right sin bio founder or directory
consumer founder whatever it might be
right and there's a pretty standard set
of questions that you might want to ask
somebody right a user acquisition or how
you're building your team or what do you
want to build whatever it might be right
and
the absolute top you know 0.1 percent
Founders the the the level of clarity
that they have about every single aspect
of the business
it's pretty mind-blowing to be honest
like for for the really best ones right
I I I'll always kind of remember uh you
know one of our one of our Founders we
were talking about user acquisition and
in a typical kind of you know founder
for user acquisition might say something
like you know oh well like we're just
gonna do paid ads right gonna do
Facebook or Instagram ads right when you
ask them how they would acquire their
first 500 customers right and this
founder is like no no actually we're not
doing any paid at all to begin with
instead what we're going to do is we're
this is like a kind of like pet wellness
company we're going to go to you know
Washington Square Park and we're going
to do it on a Saturday morning from 9 to
12 and we're going to hand out these
kinds of flyers and we're specifically
looking for you know 25 to 35 year old
women who have you know disposable
income of you know 150 to 300 000 a year
and then like we're also building a
community it was just they would they
would go on for five to ten minutes on
one small specific piece of the business
and that is how you know I think uh like
what who what's truly separating kind of
like wheat from chaff when it comes to
Founders yeah how did you guys get
started like this is such like a a
relatively unique way to do this uh but
like you're not doing it on Sand Hill
Road uh you're not doing it from uh the
halls of some massive institution yeah
uh you have a crazy crazy story like
just walk me through how does contrary
get started yeah for sure so so the
story itself actually uh yeah it's
pretty wild so um it's pretty loud yeah
so so uh from New Jersey right school in
Boston
really kind of found my interest in
school in Boston does that mean Harvard
no yes no maybe Northeastern
Northeastern all right all right people
say school in Boston you never know it's
a 50 50. no uh yeah so went to
Northeastern
um I was one of those guys who got
rejected from you know pan or some of
the other IVs and kind of I didn't even
know those schools existed yeah yeah
well that's what happens when you go to
like when you go to like kind of like uh
I don't know but yeah I went to like a a
public high school in in rural New
Jersey and it was one of those places
where the guidance counselors as long as
you got into any yeah you college at all
it was like job well done yeah so the uh
uh the whole college counselor in a high
school really has a lot more power than
people probably assigned to like in
hindsight yeah like literally kids would
go talk and they'd be like uh I don't
think that you should even apply yeah to
these 40 top schools instead let's apply
to local Community College like that
literally sets people off on damn past
in life it's egregious I mean 60 of my
high school class went to a community
college
60 percent
it's crazy right and and I think out of
a class of 430
10 of us maybe 15 went to a private
four-year University wow
crazy yeah so I totally agree it like
sets you up so you're one of ten there
that's a sign of Excellence yeah so got
out no uh and and so yeah so winter
Northeastern basically found my interest
in Tech and startups while I was there
so so worked on a payments company uh
which is funny is a good story there
toast was actually uh our biggest
competitor there were there were two
seed stage companies in Boston about a
decade ago working on payments for
full-service restaurants one was us one
was toast toast became a 10 billion
dollar company we died uh so that was
that was my first kind of experience in
in building and and that was actually
where I hatched the idea for what became
contrary because
I was in Boston spending time with
a dozen or so people from the different
universities right and Delhi and
actually it was one of them right it was
at MIT at the time and uh this guy
nasara Yasin I don't know Staley like
Nas was at Harvard at the time right so
there were a dozen of us all of whom I
thought were sharp entrepreneurial had
good hustle all those kinds of things
and we're going to go on and do great
things but it was really interesting to
me that when you actually took a step
back for people like this in their
earliest days nobody was actually doing
anything in a systematic way to identify
and capture that Talent specifically
they were largely just left to this kind
of random walk of of life right and and
so
um happy idea originally for contrary at
the time as a result of that went out to
SF after graduated it was an early
employee to start up and then maybe
three four years later swung back around
to it when I was thinking about what I
wanted to do next and I I knew that I
wanted to spend the next decade plus
building something really special and
and thought about that concept for what
became contrary and thought look you
know nothing like this exists in the in
in the Venture world right you know
Venture is is still pretty traditional
it's still pretty you know two people
and a dog you know seed stage Fund in
City acts that are doing yet the same
thing as everybody else what if you can
actually build one of the best firms of
Our Generation off of that Insight of
the person before the idea
um and so just kind of jumped in and the
rest is history no you didn't jump in
come on so you guys have found LPS at
blackjack tables on ski trips all kinds
of different explained what is the
fundraising strategy so well let's talk
about let's talk about the the very
first fund right so we're so we're five
years in actually next week will be five
years since starting right and so so the
first fund right uh so if we go back to
kind of jumping right in
once I decided that I wanted to work on
contrary right
[Music]
um
I had to be all in right and when you
think about raising money for a fund
versus a startup
you know I I always thought that raising
money for a fun would I knew it would be
harder right
um but I thought it would be doable
maybe I don't know 30 to 50 harder let's
say than raising money for a seed stage
startup right uh turns out when you know
you didn't go to Harvard or or you know
you didn't work at you know sequoia or
whatever it is it's orders of magnitude
harder right to raise your first fund
when you have not worked in Venture
prior and so uh one of our very first
LPS
uh I I uh I essentially snuck into salt
uh full conference like Anthony
scaramucci's uh conference that's right
that's right I saw him fixing I gotta
tell I got a ton I don't think I've ever
told them how did you sneak in did you
just like walk in and they just didn't
stop you or did you like go through the
service door so there was a there was a
guy that I had cold email so I took a I
I found like a sixty dollar round-trip
flight from SF to Vegas uh and I was
those are lit
those are wild if you're going at the
right time on like a Friday afternoon
some of the most unbelievable
experiences in my life I once flew
spirit and in an actual brawl started on
directly across the aisle from me and
then it continued at the baggage claim
yeah people don't understand so like
you're you're on a FL on a plane from
San Francisco going to Vegas with these
everyone is going to party and some
people start earlier yeah and so while
you're on a Spirit Airline flight uh it
gets wild 100 yeah unbelievable yeah so
so had the 60 Frontier flight in and
then immediately it was it was a 24-hour
gig basically right so I I kind of you
know land went straight to I think it
was the Venetian or something like that
right and I had cold emailed a few
people beforehand and said hey saw that
you're gonna also be at sauce right uh
you know like let's beat up right yeah
yeah and so and so the one guy uh we
were supposed to meet and he said hey
like I'm in this area right of of of of
the conference um and so basically went
to the security people right who are
kind of blocking off and I said oh like
I have a meeting with Mark right uh and
like I'm not like I'm not I basically
don't have a takeover like I'm meeting
this guy down there like can I get in
and they just let me in uh and they
didn't even nearly ask and so so that
was how I got in and then I I didn't
leave the cordoned off zone for like 12
hours yes because of course once you're
in totally yeah so I was like I'm not
I'm not I'm not leaving this right so so
stayed in for the entire day and then in
the evening I left because I saw that a
lot of people were kind of flooding out
and then I went and just started playing
Blackjack at the various blackjack
tables with people who had the salt name
tags yeah and so I just could have kind
of a ghost sit right next to them
basically in stripe strike up
conversation tell what we're doing and
and yeah it landed we got two LPS out of
that you know for our first our first
one was only a couple million dollars
right but you know I got two LPS out of
that so good trip 15 of our first one
yeah and then I slept
well originally I I was supposed to the
the Frontier flight back was like five
six a.m the next morning so in in my
mind I was like oh I'll just stay up all
night of course and then you go back how
old are you at this time
23. yeah of course yeah well that's what
you're gonna do anyways in Vegas of
course yeah but I sent myself a budget
immediately lost it that evening right
and so I I I I literally I I will never
forget this i s I tried to sleep on the
cold hard floor of the Vegas McCarran
International Airport with my backpack
and had the most crippling lower back
pain the next month
yeah of course well also if you've ever
slept in an airport which I don't want
to admit that I slept many times in here
yeah uh sometimes missed flights but
other times like ah you know why I go
get a hotel I would take a flight in the
morning yeah
um and I actually have a video once I
was uh you can't lose your bag that's
one of the big things right you don't
want somebody steal your bags so you
like basically somehow lay on your bag
or tie it to yourself or whatever
it's a thing it's a thing I didn't make
the rules this is the thing uh and so I
was laying there and then all of a
sudden I woke up at like 2 30 in the
morning and a guy is uh vacuuming oh
yeah yeah and I was like so arrogant I
was like hey man I'm sleeping over here
and he was like get the [ __ ] out of my
way yeah yeah yeah so you forget my job
bro yeah you forget that like you could
try to sleep in the airport but like
it's not really that easy to sleep when
things are going on it is not and they
had because they during uh during like
the I don't know three to five a.m
whatever they don't let you even check
in right so yeah I wasn't even in the
airport I was in the lobby oh you're in
the lobby oh see so when I've done it
I've already been in yeah and then you
stay you can't go outside the gate or
they have a connection or something you
can do that but when you don't like they
shut down the airport for a few hours at
night and so it was literally just a
cold hard
all right so then you just go back and
you're like I got two LPS good trip yeah
and so in it and so it was that process
for you know it took almost 2 years to
raise our our first fund uh you know
which one ended up being like two and a
half million basically and so you know
it's how many companies you invest the
two and a half million not twenty yeah
we've always run a pretty concentrated
book so the first one was they call it
100K checks basically into 20 or so
companies we've always been concentrated
still still are today but yeah I mean
you know the the Journey of contrary in
the early days was just you know
Relentless scrappiness right you didn't
really know anyone so you're scrapping
us to find the LPS but there's also this
story where uh your largest LP on your
birthday is like uh no mas I'm gonna
send this one out explain that so same
fund yeah it's the same fund right so so
I spent you know almost two years
running around had 1300 meetings to
raise our first fund right didn't know
anybody didn't know anything who are
these people are they doctors lawyers
are they like other VCS are they
Founders yeah it's a combination so so I
it was a lot of of tech folks there
ended up being a lot of tech folks um
and then uh I'd say it was mostly split
between Wall Street folks and Tech folks
and the reason I ended up actually
moving out to SF and and living out
there was because I would go on these
trips to SF I would crash on my friend's
couch and I would go meet people and the
number of folks that I would get
pinballed around to was unbelievable and
so you know people talk about you know
the demise of SF whatever and I I don't
know what it's going to be like post
covid but come on don't softball at it
is it is it going to come back or is it
not yeah look I I
I think that unequivocally it is still
one of the best places in the world to
build a startup right I agree with that
I think people don't understand how long
it takes to build dense ecosystems of
talent yep and and so I think you know
will it ever be what it was no but on
like a percentage basis will it still be
the number one place to to kind of start
a company for some time absolutely
although Miami people get mad at me but
like I think that there's a high
probability what you just said is
accurate but what happened was uh
there's more like dissipations or Talent
across the country and maybe in the
world
um but it still is like a very good if I
was 22 that's probably where I would go
move 100 yeah I think you either go so
when we look at our own network right
now 40 of them are NSF 40 are New York
which is staggering and then 20 are
everywhere else combined right
um but that New York piece is actually
the most interesting right uh because
that was five percent ten percent
pre-pandemic right uh and and so that's
that's like a I mean that's a massive
tectonic shift right but I agree I think
like when you're in your 20s being an SF
being in New York
if you're an ambitious person
I don't think he gets much better than
that I think kind of you know once
you're a little bit older like that's
right and your Network's built
you can kind of go wherever you want
yeah that makes sense so um all right
what's the craziest company you guys
have funded like the absolute most
insane people say like wow these guys
are more technology wise or or the
founders are just one of each yeah okay
so
in terms of the founders I'd say it has
to be this company called zepto yeah is
that how you spell z-e-p-t-o okay yeah
so
um
so it's it's it's actually it's like a
10 minute delivery company uh like a go
puff but for India okay
um and so we met the founders because
they uh they actually came inbound to us
and I think we've done a decent job of
building kind of like a a kind of a
brand within a demographic of folks and
um so they came in Bound to us and we
didn't I don't know if we knew this at
the time but uh they were 17. and so uh
and they said hey you know we uh both
got into Stanford we want to build this
company in India
um if you give us 100K uh we'll defer
admission to Stanford and and and build
this company and so he said okay well
we've never done an investment in India
before don't really have a network in
India don't really know anyone in India
right
um but these guys going back to Clarity
of thought
it was unbelievable I mean for for 17
year olds right the the level of clarity
that they had about every single aspect
of how they were going to go about you
know getting their first customers
scaling this thing to the moon like what
they actually wanted to build long term
was was Unreal and so we said okay well
if we're really putting our money where
our mouth is here and talent is is what
we believe in more than anything else
right like let's just do it and see what
happens right and so we give him 100K uh
and then tracked him for six months and
and they continue they actually
dramatically surpassed our expectations
they made some great hires they were
executing like hell
um and so we gave him another few
hundred thousand a half a million
whatever it was and fast forward to
today uh 18 24 months later now fastest
growing startup in India's history uh a
thousand employees hundreds of millions
in Revenue in their 19 now
crazy unbelievable yeah uh when you go
back was it just Clarity of thought or
was there other things that in hindsight
you're like man that was a really good
signal as to like this was gonna happen
yeah I honestly I do think it was
Clarity of thought it was you know
the level of sophistication and thought
and maturity that they had
they could have easily gone toe-to-toe
with somebody twice their age and so
even if you just extrapolate off of that
right and you say okay well
these guys are 17 like can you only
imagine how good they're going to be in
5 or 10 or 15 years right even if this
company doesn't work out you know no
hard feelings it's a hundred thousand
dollars we live to fight another day
right but the upside is massive so yeah
I think ultimately it's just it's just
when you spoke with them you knew hey
Like These Guys these guys are special
right and we're in a business of
benchmarking at the end of the day right
you're talking to hundreds or thousands
of Founders and you're simply just
trying to calibrate hey how how sharp
sophisticated is somebody relative to
their age experience whatever and and
these guys are off the charts so a lot
of people don't realize how important
big is in Venture Capital yeah right uh
we've seen a lot of uh companies blow up
in crypto world all this stuff yeah and
people are freaking out and they don't
realize like no actually that is the
entire Venture Capital model of uh it
you want it to be either as big as
possible or it's gonna end up being a
big crater in the ground totally but if
it ends up being small small victory or
small loss then actually it wasn't a
venture type company yeah I mean we we
exactly I mean we I you could you could
talk to LPS or whatever right like if
if your loss ratio
is zero you're actually not doing it the
right way right in any Adventure I mean
so if you take if you take you know uh
our portfolio let's say like like ours
right which is typically you know pretty
early stage it's 75 what we're doing is
kind of precedes series a the remainder
is kind of maybe series a series b a
little bit of early series C but if
you're looking at it from a purely kind
of pre-seed seed series a point of view
at the seed in a 20 company portfolio
you know we're underwriting that half of
these are going to go to zero
out of the remaining 10 5 to 10 do kind
of sorry five of them do kind of one to
two x in Aggregate and five of those out
of those 20 but really two or three out
of those 20 are the ones that are
actually driving the returns um so yeah
I mean that's that's basically how the
model works and and the loss ratio needs
to be higher than zero otherwise the
Venture model won't work so yeah
what is the craziest technology that you
guys have invested in yeah yeah so
um
it's good one there are a couple a
couple options uh
so we invested in this in this company
called red leader which is essentially
building
software-defined lidar
um for all different kinds of
applications autonomous vehicles
whatever
um software defined yeah yeah all right
so lidar just for those that don't know
uh explain it yeah so so it's
essentially uh you can think about it as
uh kind of like what waymo and and if
you've ever seen any of those like Uber
or autonomous vehicles essentially what
what happens is there it sensors right
that you're putting all around a vehicle
and and ultimately it's it's building an
image of the world a kind of in front
directly in front of you right and then
you're you're using kind of autonomous
technology to help the car or whatever
you're dealing with a helicopter
navigate that and it's basically
shooting light out and like
understanding the object the depth all
that type of stuff you described it much
better than I would hence why I
offloaded that to you uh but but it is a
technology that is really I think
self-driving cars were how most people
have learned about it what is you said
software driven lidar is that fine
software defined what does that mean
yeah and so what's interesting is if you
if you look at some of the kind of
incumbents in the space companies like
velodyne or whomever right
um they are using a much more
traditional kind of like Tech and
Hardware stack whereas red leader this
company is like software is at the core
of the infrastructure they're not it's
not so much the the lidar itself that
they're innovating on right it's it's
the software and the code actually that
they're writing which enables them to
image at a dramatically higher kind of
frequency than any of the existing folks
and so if we were to pull this up and
I'll show you after but you look at a
demo video that they have
and relative to kind of like the current
state of the art and it's it's stunning
they literally invented math uh like to
make this Tech work it's it's
unbelievable and so they've been working
on it for
four or five years where are they using
it for
um the initial application is going to
be AVS yeah autonomous vehicles um but
it has kind of a broadcast I recently
saw hopeless isn't a competitor appears
but I saw uh there was like a plane that
was flying over the Amazon yeah and they
were using I think lidar and they were
uncovering uh civilizations ah yeah
along the Amazon river that were
previously not known yeah and a huge
piece of it was uh people thought it was
so uninhabitable or whatever uh but by
flying over even though there's the tree
canopy they were shooting the lidar down
and like uncovering this [ __ ] yeah and
they were like yo people used to live
there right yeah and so like again it's
different than autonomous vehicles but
like I was blown away I spent probably
two hours I don't want to admit that but
I spent two hours on the internet like
looking at images of people's lives from
thousands of years ago this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep it's nuts
yeah it's absolutely nuts yeah and so I
think like these like there are dozens
of applications here and frankly a lot
of lidar companies have been
a total waste of money and time and
effort right there's been billions of I
mean I think Ford has always has been
you know two years away from from
autonomous vehicles for the past decade
now
uh so I saw Elon congratulate the Ford
CEO on selling like a couple thousand
electric vehicles
yeah exactly so it's like you know the
the promise of lidar the promise of AVS
who knows right but I think that the raw
Tech when you look at what red leader
and some of these others have built it's
it's just stunning and and I think it
makes you really excited for for the
future so so uh Tesla has
um
autopilot what yeah whatever name they
want to use but basically you can pull
down twice on the freaking uh drive
stick or whatever and it stays in the
lane on the highway that was like the
only experience I'd ever seen was like
it stays in the lane on the highway
slows down of cars in front of it it can
kind of tell right it's got the nice
imagery whatever
they have a recent update now it's
driving in cities
really I have a friend uh who sent me
the video he's more courageous than me
he's sitting in his driveway he puts in
the coffee shop like you know probably a
mile and a half two miles and he has to
go to Red Lights stop signs turn like
the whole thing yeah he like took a
video yeah and I was like
oh [ __ ] wow like like you can just see
like okay cool now I don't think it's
anywhere near where like you know the
whole like people are going to be
sitting in the back and no one's gonna
be at the at the steering wheel have you
seen what Cruz is doing though with the
robo taxis and what are they doing yeah
so so so they have they've done this
yeah yeah so they're the exactly the
same so if you go on I think on Twitter
actually Kyle vote who's the the CEO I
think he has some some videos uh of they
just started it they just opened it up
to the public a couple months ago
um and it's only an SF and yeah you can
hail a cruise fully autonomous end to
end and you sit in the back seat and the
cruise just drives you so an hour ago
Kyle tweeted and said the Press they say
autonomous vehicles are overhyped and
are still five to ten years away and
then he said us meaning Cruz at this
moment there are a hundred Crews
autonomous vehicles and driverless mode
in San Francisco and many are currently
carrying passengers and he has an image
from 290 nights ago with all the little
dots on it there you go holy [ __ ]
so it's it's definitely real with
cruising itself I think the question now
is like how do you how do you actually
scale this right I mean they've been the
cruise cars have been driving around SF
for years right mapping it and and and
you know I mean there's just so many
permutations of things that could go
wrong right but uh they're doing it in
SF so you know
so they have the cars uh they're all
branded Crews and uh they have them like
all parked in like a little uh parking
lot then there's taken off and they say
on your Mark gets that go have you seen
the video of the cruise car getting
pulled over by by the police officers
this is hilarious you bought it you got
it you gotta maybe after this whatever
you gotta you gotta watch it a cruise uh
you know AV taxi got got pulled over by
some cops I don't think they realized
that there wasn't a
in the car yo so there's nobody in this
car nobody in this car yeah I'm watching
the video right now uh YouTube will take
it down if we put it up probably uh but
it says that they launched daytime
driverless rides service is live for
Cruisers and we'll launch uh to public
or whatever yeah uh and literally they
have the video and there is nobody in
the drivers there's nobody in the car
and they're interviewing these two uh
ladies and they're having the time of
their life in the back it's nuts it's
nuts yeah
so are they the farthest ahead I I think
when it comes to actually I mean they're
the only one that I know of that has
done this end to end right now uh but
it's just in San Francisco right and so
we'll be curious to see how much they
can basically how quickly they can scale
at different cities right but yeah
they're the only ones that I know right
now that are doing it uh like truly end
to end in a city it's wild yeah and they
have videos of people I guess uh trying
to trick the cruise vehicles at night
like there's a guy they they claim I
think it's real I mean they have a video
of them trying to do it uh he says the
driverless Cruise autonomous vehicle was
tracking both the person and the dog and
managed to Swerve to avoid a collision
is it risking your life to prank an
autonomous vehicle is stupid but it's
your call just leave your dog out of it
and it's literally a video of a guy it's
at night the car's driving down the road
and he like is in the road and darts at
the cruise and the crew swerves a voice
and then like immediately sends on the
break yeah that is nuts I don't doubt I
mean people are people are stupid right
but uh yeah it's crazy all right so you
guys got the lidar what are other some
crazy Technologies yeah yeah
um like what's it like what is the
future that's what I want to talk about
what is the what is the future stuff
that people are like there's no way
that's gonna work yeah yeah
um
what are your thoughts on Android yeah I
love it I'm surprised that uh it took
Palmer and the underworld team to say
hey we should use the most Cutting Edge
technology in the defense of our country
100 yeah I mean that's that's so much
that's what we should talk about right I
mean so we're we're uh we're investors
in Android and and I think you know
I I mean like you said it's it's it's
it's the most logical extension of of
you know talking about like tech for the
future right and and in defense of uh
not only the country but just democracy
right and it was funny right because I
think for a long time
anderill was
uh I think kind of
tacitly uh like poo pooed right amongst
a lot of folks in the in the Venture the
tech world right and then something like
Ukraine happens and all of a sudden you
realize
okay well actually maybe defense is
important right uh it is important for
democracy and for this country right and
and and and kind of building the next
gen Lockheed right at the 21st century
Lockheed is an incredibly important
mission right uh and and something that
if we're not going to do it China
remembers going to do it and and and you
know that's that's it right so yeah I
mean I think that that's been that's
been fascinating I was I had a chance to
drop by the new they just opened up some
new headquarters in LA
you know four or five months ago that's
cool yeah it's awesome yeah yeah matters
give me a kind of like a tour of some of
the new tech and buildings
um uh how much of it is war versus like
other types of uh uses so yeah a hostage
rescue or humanitarian Aid or whatever
like there's so many things that the
clinical government or the the defense
contractors actually participate in it's
not all like let's go kill people but
how much of that business is the other
stuff yeah well so so so Andrew their
whole model is essentially kind of
predicated around the inverse of the
traditional kind of Defense Prime model
right which is uh you know typically
kind of you you you know kind of wait
for the dod or whomever to kind of like
put out some RFP or anything if you
build something for it and you bid and
then you built the project right and you
use the government's money to build the
project so basically the government is
taking the risk that you're going to be
able to build it that's right yeah um
Andrew's basically flipping on his head
right and so so they they're building
uh through discussions with a lot of
folks obviously in the defense Community
right but they're they're building in
products that they think will resonate
ultimately right and they're taking that
risk and then selling it right so so the
first one uh the first kind of probably
the launch was essentially just like a
century a century tower for uh initially
for the border right
um and it's having a bunch what's a
century Tower meaning uh just like uh
just like literally like a 25 foot Tower
uh that you'll put you know on a ranch
in South Texas somewhere and it can be
used to detect you know whether it's
like illegal immigrants or uh drugs it's
got probably cameras it's got like a
heat sensors exactly anything you might
imagine like yeah sensors like infrared
you know you name it right and so and
then they're just putting all these
different Sentry Towers every X you know
miles that Sail On the Border and so
that was the thing so you're saying that
Andrew built the wall
building a digital wall yes okay
uh so so that was kind of like the the
full size of the political aisle got
excited there that's right yeah
yeah so uh so that was kind of V1 right
and and and now they have a bunch of
other product lines essentially that
they're launching her so they they
recently acquired this company I forget
the name of it I think it's based out of
Australia and and they're building like
an autonomous sub uh and they have
another one uh that's essentially like
an autonomous helicopter right or they
have another one that is it just sounds
like video games it's unreal yeah like
we're just gonna be sitting here with
joysticks and we're like oh this is my
submarine just blew up your submarine
that had no people in yeah well speak
about like the future I mean the future
right like the future of warfare is a
largely human-less
future right like that's just what we're
going to Trend towards I mean the the
reason why Society is
get upset with war at times right is is
either you know it just goes on forever
and costs hundreds of billions of
dollars number one right or number two
like human casualties right so if you're
able to remove human casualties from
that equation number one it's a great
thing for the world but number two you
know and this would be interesting I I
do wonder if it actually ends up
enabling more net new like
microaggression right because if you can
just send your drones out like my robots
killed your robots yeah like no humans
died yeah exactly if I have a lot of
money well whatever right you know what
Talon robot is Talent t-a-l-o-n uh so
when I was in the military
um at one point I was a combat engineer
which sounds it has a word engineer in
it there's no engineering
um basically they were like you guys are
gonna do roadside clearance like go look
for bombs and basically be bait right
like horrible uh and so in the train up
uh to go to Iraq they're like oh we have
these robots yeah and you're like sweet
robots that sounds cool yeah and they
literally would uh train there was like
actual people trained and then they kind
of like field trained a couple of people
in case that person got hurt or I wasn't
there or whatever yeah and so this robot
would like get out of the vehicle like
you'd like pulled out of the vehicle
you'd put it there and you're standing
like as far away from obviously what you
think could be a a bomb yeah and so you
like maneuver it down there like
literally like a you know uh uh like a
uh or a car or whatever like a
um you know remote control car or
whatever you get it down there and it's
got this big ass arm and it has like the
pinchers on the end yeah it had a camera
so you're looking through to see what it
sees yeah and the people who are very
well trained could literally pick up
like an m m with the Pinchers and not
crush it oh wow like that was the level
of uh one sophistication but also two
the ability of the machine yeah so we're
like we they were badasses we're let's
go we're there we got the robot in the
back right first couple of missions we
go yeah and uh uh all of a sudden we
think we see a roadside bomb we're like
get the robot yeah pull that bad boy out
go down four hours later
not a bomb robot comes back pack it up
go yeah half a mile down the road we
think we see a bomb
guess what happened to that robot after
like three missions we're like leave the
robot at the thing if you're in one of
the fun Vehicles just run the [ __ ] over
we'll figure out if it's a bomb it's
like I always think about like that
specific experience as like yeah
obviously the technology was incredible
like at the time 2008 2009 so like you
know more than 10 years ago they had
this technology but like humans still
had to use it yeah and whether we were
smart or dumb yeah we just left it
behind yeah and then we just go use it
it's like how do you think about the
human element to some of these
Technologies they get built like are we
now at a place where the humans
recognize like no this is actually
better than the humans doing it yeah
well I think we're getting there right
and like I think per what you said right
I think in in 0809 like you know there's
a lot of tech that's just too far ahead
of its time I mean this is the
definition of hype cycle right like this
is what happens every one or two
whatever years right I mean right now
we're in the generative I hypestacker I
don't know if you saw the the chat you
know Chat gpt3 thing that came out
yesterday right so like you know I think
that's significantly more mature than
the last AIML hype cycle three four
years ago I bet it was you know AIML it
was self-driving cars it was you know uh
yeah yeah yeah it was
um I mean I don't know right we could
keep going back out here back every one
or two years there's no mess yeah yeah
exactly and and the vast majority of
them
uh don't fulfill the the the stated aims
right and and they're just too far ahead
of the time for for the hype but I think
ultimately what happens right is your
your attack that in 0809 was was like
incredible for the time but still very
little real world human applicability
you know I think we're inching pretty
close I mean you look at some of the
some of the videos now what the military
is using or some of the robots or even
you look at like what Boston Dynamics
has done right and
um
I you know I I we're not there yet uh
with I think kind of human like
hand-to-hand combat for example right
you're saying humans could still beat up
the robot but like it's getting harder I
think it's getting closer yeah and I
think I think I think when it comes to
drones
um I think we're pretty close right like
I I think you were already pretty close
right and so I have a friend who lives
in Texas and you know in Texas they uh
they think that they can't be [ __ ]
with and so you I remember joking I was
like what are you gonna do when the
drones come yeah and he was I'm gonna
shoot him out of the sky and I was like
that's a great answer but uh I was like
do you understand how quick these things
are or whatever and he like started
thinking about it and like you could
tell that he didn't want to say it but
he was like oh [ __ ] I can't shoot that
out of the sky no way or if you have
drone swarms right if you imagine having
to send 400 drones at you that cost a
couple hundred dollars each to
manufacture and they're all attached
with you know some small bomb or
whatever right what's up with San
Francisco their arm in the room robots
now to kill people saw that just
yesterday is that real it's unbelievable
I mean I didn't I didn't actually read
the article but uh it's on the internet
just read the headlines
yeah if it's if it's legitimate then
it's it's
bizarre why why would San Francisco be
the first city to no I don't think it's
bizarre I think this is like a perfect
San Francisco thing to do yeah is to
like oh we have no Law and Order so like
now we have robots with weapons as our
Law and Order but it's the same thing
like the bathroom the uh like the five
million dollar bathroom whatever yeah
how much it was yeah uh they have like a
ribbon cutting ceremony because they
built a public bathroom right and it's
like uh oh we have no infrastructure no
look at this bathroom that we built yeah
same thing here is like we have no Law
and Order people get mad like you know
what the solution is they're not just
like put police officers on Beats in the
city yeah let's get robots with guns
yeah and it's uh to any normal person
outside of like the bureaucratic like
apparatus you're like uh I can think of
a lot of ways this goes really bad yeah
and then by the way like God forbid that
these robots kill somebody yeah and it
comes out that they shouldn't have yeah
who gets in trouble yeah well I mean
they're gonna put the robot in jail yeah
this goes back to to the self-driving me
like a cruise and everybody I mean this
is why they spent years and billions of
dollars and millions of miles driven
right like to prevent this because all
it takes is one what's going on with uh
gbt3 and all these AI models like yeah
uh the generative art for those that
don't know you basically uh type in a
prompt a prompt is just like a sentence
you could say like uh uh show me a photo
of a person sitting on a park bench with
water behind them or whatever and it
creates it's awesome like super cool not
very clear how people will use that but
like cool yeah and now there's like okay
now we have the chat now we have like
more and more and more how do you guys
look at this yeah you know I I think for
us
um
we always I should say number one we
rarely if ever Chase hype Cycles okay I
think as a firm the the view is that
the hype Cycles themselves maybe you
have one or two companies that emerge
from these
um that end up being some degree of
successful but the companies that are
going to be multi-billion dollar
companies a decade from now are often
spaces that you know people aren't
really looking in right uh they're kind
of undiscovered they're unsexy like
almost by definition there's not a ton
of hype behind them so so I should have
it all this but yeah we rarely kind of
like engage in hype Cycles I think when
it comes to something like GPT 3
specifically or the generator generated
AI stuff you know I I think for me
there's always a question of like
what is the durable source of value that
is being created at the end of the day
and is it sustainable right and you look
at
um how do you how do you measure that I
I think you just you can just look at it
and and like like art is a good example
right like what like the real world
utility of of me saying like hey draw a
picture of you know Anthony sitting in
the park right
it's nice it's it's it's it's helpful
but it feels a lot more like a feature
than it does like a meaningful platform
or something that people are going to
pay you know SAS style model of of
Revenue off of right and so
um yeah I I guess what I'd say like
we're
we tend to be Skeptics of these kinds of
things and when you look at different
like Innovation waves right kind of like
SAS and mobile and and and and whatever
it might be
um
whether the the advantages accrue to the
startups or the incumbents I think tells
a lot too so a lot Bill kind of wrote a
post about this recently which which I
think did a good job of it encapsulating
some of my views here too but uh you
know I think the reason the mobile wave
for example wasn't
super protracted relative to SAS as an
example is because the incumbents the
the Facebooks the Googles have never
they ended up capturing a lot of that
value pretty quickly right uh within
like a really like the burst of time was
like three to four year periods like
2009 are there any companies that end up
being [ __ ] massive that didn't work
out of the gate
oh all the time but no I don't know
which one pivot though yeah but like
that's not but that's okay so you're
saying like oh okay yeah I can't think
of any like slack right I think you're
like oh it was the video game or
whatever right exactly uh but like slack
was a different product that's right and
then it was like pretty obvious I think
from what I understand from that story
like immediately yeah Twitter was out of
audio but like pretty quickly people
were like oh this is cool and it started
to take off yeah so like I do think a
lot about uh like the 90 day or 180 day
shot clock yeah like if you start
something in 180 days it's not working
there is uh it doesn't mean that it
won't work it just means that it's
unlikely to be really really big I think
that's right yeah I think when you when
you think about like real generational
companies right like the the the 10
billion plus companies
there's usually something that almost
from inception feels like it's working
yeah I agree I agree I think I think
there are other companies that you can
make work over time but those end up
being
smaller outcomes yeah I mean we could
talk I I definitely have some views on
on
um
just kind of like the the ability to
kind of like lock versus timing versus
hard work versus whenever when it comes
to building companies what are your
thoughts I mean I I think ultimately
like this the simplified version is that
these a lot of these 10 15 20 billion
dollar plus outcomes it is the
Confluence of all of those factors right
whereas if you're I I pretty strongly
believe that like if you're a sharp
person building in the right space uh
and and somebody who can kind of like
listen to customers like with enough
grit over a five ten year period like
you can make something happen right
um I I mean I think you had Max left on
recently right like this is kind of what
they do with a firm right it's like a
firm kind of like it's been around for a
while but you kind of listen and tweak
the model and like inevitably you kind
of hit on on like a Bernie need for a
customer and then you kind of hit the
gas and go from there right so like
these things exist all the time but I
think for the truly big outcomes like in
Airbnb or whatever like pretty much from
the beginning you know it was working
right so yeah
where are you guys looking now like okay
you're not chasing the hype Cycles yeah
well what are we all missing yeah where
where are the areas that you find
interesting yeah um well so I think for
us it depends on on kind of what stage
we're at as a firm right so pre-seed
seed series a we're laser focused on the
person right we actually don't care what
they're like what space they're building
right I don't care if it's digital
health or or or you know fintech or
infrastructure or whatever it is as long
as this is a person that you know we've
known for a period of time we think is
top point one percent and it's doing
something really interesting like we
have enough conviction to write them a
check at the early stage and and see
what they can make happen
um when we get to a later stage right uh
kind of call it series B and Beyond
that's when we start to get more
thematic I'd say as a firm race I think
that's that's when you look at a company
let's say you know fintech
infrastructure right and you're looking
at hey in in the FP and a space you know
what are the five companies that we
think are world class in this space
right now and what is the one company in
that space that we think is going to in
right that we think is going to be a
multi-billion dollar outcome so depends
on the stage but I'd say in general
right now we're still spending a lot of
our time in like digital health and and
then uh what I'll call like fintech
infrastructure like those are two spaces
that were well you guys not back a
Founder if uh you haven't known them
before
um no we will uh we will but I'd say
it's it's the minority of what we do
yeah so if I kind of look at where where
we're deploying Capital today probably
30 to 35 of we're doing is kind of from
this closed-loop network of folks that
we've built that we've gotten to know
you know through a Fellowship Community
whatever it might be I think probably 30
35 is from our software platform so we
build a pretty sophisticated software
platform uh it's kind of systematically
identifying and tracking great talent
and then we'd have what I'll call like
traditional sources right found
referrals whatever it may be and and
that's the remaining 20 30 that's
essentially what the breakdown looks
like but all things equal we like
backing people that
come from our Network and and folks that
um ultimately kind of like have a uh uh
like we have some kind of edge in in
finding them first and understanding
like hey why is contrary seeing this
deal right not just getting the the deal
that everybody else has passed on so
it's like real adverse selection there I
think is this the future of venture
capital firms like is this what they're
gonna look like
it's a great question I mean I think the
answer is yes but uh but is it just one
type of firm or whether will this be one
of many strategies that can be
successful I think it'll be I think
it'll be one of several but if if we
look at a decade from now and you ask
yourself hey Eric like what like what
does venture look like in in a decade
and I essentially think three things
will win uh I think number one you'll
need some degree of Technology at your
core
number two you'll need talent and
community and number three you'll need
distribution you know content media
whatever right and I think the firms
that will win right the the next kind of
andreessens or YC's or whatever will
have all three of those in Spades and
then I think you know there will be
firms that exist that do one or two of
those very well right or even
individuals right I mean obviously like
you've done a great job right kind of
building it like that last one a
distribution right like you have you
know world-class brand and community and
whatever right and so there will be
pieces of the puzzle and people who can
kind of carve out their niches within
those but I think if you're trying to
build the next entries and whatever like
I think you need to ultimately have
those three things in Spades so yeah
what are the strategies that people are
chasing now that you think won't work in
Venture yeah
I tend to be not uh not as much of a fan
of of what I'll call
um
like thematic Venture funds right uh and
there are some that do exceptional work
and I think our Our Best in Class I
think like uh like a rivet for fintech
or you know amplify with the Enterprise
infrastructure like there are some
world-class firms that that do that but
I think there are a lot of firms that do
that and it's it's principally a
marketing Endeavor more than anything
else right so they'll say oh you know
we're uh we're uh you know a cyber
Security fund right and as a result of
that you know we're you should you
should give us Capital because we're you
know deeply deeply knowledgeable about
this right but and so from an LP point
of view I think it can be enticing or
alluring right because you're saying wow
well I'm looking for a cyber fund and
these guys brand themselves as a cyber
fund so they must be the best right but
when you look at it
the best
Venture Platforms in the world right the
Sequoias the intracens the founders
funds whomever
they're all generalists right and
they're all generalists for a reason
right they're generous because
the best companies don't discriminate
right you know the best companies are in
Enterprise SAS and you know fintech and
consumer and everything between right
like your job at the end of the day
should be to identifying back the best
Founders full stop
regardless of what they're building
right regardless of the space that
they're building in so yeah I think
that's kind of
um
uh
I think one that I feel pretty strongly
about there's also something I think
somebody like kind of some of the some
of the kind of like uh tier two tier
three accelerators as well like I think
that's a ship that has long since sailed
I think YC is is I mean they've just
built such brand Equity at this point
um but yeah
one of my last questions for you is uh
if I want to start a company yeah in the
future what is the things that I should
do beforehand to get positioned to have
the skill set experience Network
Etc uh to be able to start that business
let's say I'm coming out of college and
I'm like one day I want to start a
company what is a maybe not the only
path but a good path for me to pursue
yeah I think it depends on the kind of
company that you want to start right so
I think if if you're interested in
starting you know in in Enterprise
infrastructure company right and I think
that's a much different path than if you
want to go start a fintech company or
whatever Captain right and I think you
know in Enterprise infrastructure for
example when you look at many of the
very successful companies that have been
started in that space right if you look
at a rubric or a samsara or whomever
right
um
they're started by people who are
oftentimes in their 40s typically right
who have spent 20 years basically like
deeply understanding like how
infrastructure works at large-scale
Enterprises right so that's that Tech
right but I'd say for your for your
typical kind of new grad if you're
thinking about hey you know I want to
start a company the best advice that I
could possibly give them is to go work
at a
series a to series C hyper growth
startup one that's backed by you know a
top five maybe top 10 firm one that has
somewhere from 20 to 50 people
and then just go do whatever it possibly
takes to learn just get your hands dirty
right I mean I think about as like a
ramp or a retool or whatever right like
if you can get in early at one of those
companies
the velocity of learning that you'll
have over the next two three four years
will be unequivocally higher than
anything that you could ever get by
working at a Fang company or working at
a series D or C or you know soon to be
public kind of company and you learn so
much on somebody else's dime brand
credibility reputation right that by the
time you're ready to kind of spin out
and start your own company you know the
fundamentals and and you know let's say
you're working at ramp right you don't
have to go start a fintech company right
it doesn't matter at that point you've
learned a broad-based skill set that's
pretty generalizable right uh and then
you go build so that would be my best
advice it's like if you're a new grad
thinking about starting a company over
the next two to four years
and you don't already have the idea that
you want to work on today
go work at you know a ramp style company
um for a couple years learned under some
of the best most ambitious
entrepreneurial people in the world and
then spin out and do your own thing I
think that's a great idea uh what about
friend groups like Founders who end up
being successful usually tend to be
around other Founders that are
successful is that yeah yeah I I think
it's fair I think like when we look at
even kind of within contrary like the
the networks of people that have been
formed
um or even if I go all the way back to
the Genesis of country right you know a
decade or so ago
[Music]
um
I think the the most ambitious people
associate themselves with other really
ambitious entrepreneurial people and so
when I look at the founders that were
backing who are you know earlier in
their careers right I can kind of call
like 20 to
26 27. yeah for the most part I mean
they have a small pocket of half a dozen
to dozen friends in their city that
they're living with you know living in a
hacker house with like spending time
with working on projects with right and
and
um and this stuff matters right and it
matters because you're building trust
You're Building long-term relationships
you're getting to know someone we just
back to company actually seed stage but
uh you know the founders went to college
together lived together have stayed
close sorry both NSF together and and
you know one just recruited another one
from a startup to go start the company
together right so like these things can
take time to play out but ultimately you
know Finding Your tribe right like
finding your group of people
um is super important and then that
carries on to the company that you're at
as well right if you look at again like
a ramp or an annual whomever right the
the you know the early employees at
those companies end up building their
own versions of mafias right and they
spin out and they all Angel invest in
one another's companies and they start
campaigns together right and it's really
powerful right and you there are there
are a small number of companies that
have large numbers of entrepreneurial
people and
again like if you're a new grad or
whoever like those are the pockets that
you want to look for both in friend
group and also in in colleague group so
yeah and when you think about your
day-to-day what is your like normal
schedule look like yeah
um Ebbs and flows by the time of the
year I'd say but uh you know I you know
I'd say typically today I'm
I'm in more of like a CEO style role at
a contrary so we have about 20 people on
the team now five on the investment Team
15 kind of helping us build the the
talent identification machine right
across engineering and data science and
talent and so on
um and so I spend probably
um uh maybe a third of my time
recruiting uh you know trying to kind of
bring world-class people on the team and
kind of level up with every single hire
and I spend probably a third of my time
uh on some combination of fundraising or
managing the team right kind of like
setting strategy efficient and then
probably the remaining third on
investing and supporting existing
Founders so um that's roughly the
allocation of time but it can ebb and
flow if we're fundraising you're remote
or you have a office uh remote but we
have a we have a we call like a third
space in New York I actually should just
open it up a couple months ago it's
called contrary NYC and basically like
it's an extension of
the whole thesis right which is we're
trying to build infrastructure to
support people at every step of their
Journeys right we're trying to help them
find their first jobs write them their
first check provide a home for them to
meet like-minded technologists you know
all the way through you know supporting
them for their whole journey um so yeah
we have a space that we just opened up
in New York recently it's it's pretty
awesome but um remote first is a firm
yeah and then how do you communicate
with the team is slack email uh meetings
yeah yeah we use uh we use Microsoft
teams teams
[Laughter]
some people do yeah yeah yeah I know uh
I've banned teams by the way
one of the companies uh I don't know why
the founder always wanted to use teams
and like if you don't have the app on
your phone or whatever you like can't
like call into it like it's just like it
doesn't make any sense and so I finally
got frustrated and I was like if I see
another teams
yeah yeah it is fertile yeah so no not
teams uh no so we're we just we use a
pretty traditional stack so it's it's
it's uh you know slack Zoom email
whatever and then the Cadence has been
pretty good for us actually is
um you know remote first as a team I'd
say out of the 20 maybe
a little less than half of us are in SF
and then we have a couple in La New York
whatever
um and then we kind of marry
uh that Cadence with a quarterly
in-person team off-site
um so every quarter we basically go
somewhere in person usually just in the
US right and and to kind of take three
four five days to you know do feedback
level set on where we've been where
we're headed and just have some team
bonding time in person I think it's been
there are certain people who are
obviously more energized than others
buying a person and so it's been a good
balance for us that allows everybody the
flexibility to kind of do what they want
live where they want live their own life
but but also kind of show up for their
colleagues you think people work uh as
much remote as they would in the office
or you think they work more remote than
they would in the office I think it
depends on the person right I think you
have to you have to be internally
motivated right uh and and you have to
have ambition and want to build I think
you know if you're talking about you
know Google style scale I mean there's
no there's no there's no doubt that it's
becoming massively less productive
company but I think when you're a team
of us with 20 where there's really high
accountability across the board right
it's like every single day like you have
your responsibilities right and if you
don't have your responsibilities doing
them
it's obvious right and so I think in
those kinds of environments it's
actually fine you're you have you know
for the most part senior ambitious
motivated people who are going to show
up and do great work regardless of where
they live but I think once you start
scaling meaningfully right call it past
the century mark yeah I I I I would I
don't know if I'd do it if I were a fire
CEO so but there's a war of talent right
you end up with a with a you know game
theory of talent here's why here's this
might be one of the things people
disagree with all right yeah there's not
a war of talent for the best companies
if you are a generational company people
are knocking down your door trying to
work there
right think of uh Andrew as a great
example how many companies are actually
competing with Android for talent
I don't know the answer but like I bet I
mean I I went I looked one day there's
like 200 open roles yeah right yeah and
when you look at a business like that if
you're into defense technology where you
go work for sure right and then maybe
you're just like into Tech yeah like
where else are you gonna get to build
this stuff yeah like it's just so
differentiated than everything else that
again this bombastic to say it's not a
war on talent but it is a very very big
competitive Advantage just simply the
mission that you're doing and so
naturally you are able to attract talent
that other people can't yeah I think
that's right yeah but I and I think
that's right but I think there's
you know a handful of comp we can
probably count on one or two hands those
companies and I mean frankly those are
probably the companies that people
should be trying to go to work for of
course uh but like the reason why we
want to go work there totally yeah yeah
but for the rest right like it's it's uh
you know I think it's a much tougher
sled right if you're if you don't have
the visibility yet if you don't have the
brand yet and you know employer X says
oh yeah you can stay remote and and you
say oh no you have to be in person
you know I think I think I think many
Founders that I've talked to feel like
it puts them in a hard spot right where
like especially if you're a seed or
series a right like you're still
building your company you're just trying
to get the best Engineers we're kind of
full stop right and if 95 of your
competitors are saying that Engineers
can can work you know remote
it's just hard right and you don't have
the time necessarily to be to be you
know spinning your wheels on trying to
find amazing Engineers who also want to
work full-time so uh yeah it's a hard
one but uh I think just depends on like
where you're at in the company's
Evolution so yeah that uh that makes
sense where can we send people to find
you on the internet yeah we're at
contrary.com or uh my Twitter what's
your Twitter account uh it's just first
first initial last name so e tarzinski
but it's a brutal one to spell so
contrary.com how did you get that yeah
it just was a slog but we got it yeah
yeah it just paid up yeah so we uh we we
paid but we we found if we have a
fantastic uh broker that we use
um and this person uh talk about hustle
they have unrelenting hustle we've said
we we've said that we sent them to
oh man half half a dozen of our own
portfolio companies at this point too uh
yeah he
um he will spare no uh uh spare nothing
really to help to help uh help help
people get the the domains they want so
yeah I think one time he called up
he found the so he found the owner of
the domain right and then he called up
the spouse of the owner of the domain
and told because it originally didn't
want to sell and then he told them uh
that uh did you know that so and so like
your your partner has an offer uh to buy
x.com or whatever it was for you know
fifty thousand dollars I don't know what
it was
um and he doesn't want to do it uh and
they were they went crazy they went nuts
literally the next day sold so this guy
this guy's pretty good yeah
yeah
you just gotta love people who
understand how the world that's right
that's hustle yeah that's absolute
hustle all right thank you so much for
coming and doing this we will uh we will
definitely do this again in the future
yeah appreciate it